[Musique]
pour patrouiller la savane sauvegarder
la fourmi
il fait partie des premiers Gard
forestiers de l'histoire du Kenya et à
dévoué sa vie à la protection des
animaux sauvages
l'homme connaît la brousse comme le font
de sa poche les girafes et les éléphants
non plus aucun secret pour lui assume
toi
il connaît leurs habitudes il sait où et
quand les trouver slocking
clairement le sanctuaire de Kimana au
pied du célèbre mon Kilimanjaro et le
royaume des animaux il accueille des
troupeaux de zèbre de girafe des
autruches des buffles des populations de
bêtes sauvages globalement en hausse le
nombre d'éléphants par exemple a
augmenté de 12% Kenya ou pour des sept
dernières années
une très bonne nouvelle pour un pays
dont le tourisme dépend essentiellement
de l'industrie des Safari
chiffre dans Friends Legay tire une
grande fierté
indéniable le résultat d'une politique
de conservation musclée et de lutte sans
merci contre le braconnage
d'éléphants se vend 5000 dollars au
marché noir la corne de rhinocéros elle
vaut 12 fois plus
[Musique]
alors pour Francis Legay et ses hommes
impossible de baisser la garde leur
combat contre les braconniers et
capitales sans eux bien des espèces
risquent de disparaître les rhinocéros
noirs ici sont particulièrement menacés
ils sont suivis à la trace
leur déjection sont examinées à la loupe
et soigneusement noté et rapportés
ils sont tellement rares que le seul
moyen de les voir c'est grâce à un
réseau de caméras de surveillance
les communications radio en cryptées les
caméras de surveillance et la
localisation en temps réel par GPS
qui ont transformé le travail des
garde-chasse ce week-end
des outils technologiques qui ont
surtout changé le rapport de force en
leur faveur
au fil des ans les garde-chasse le Big
life ont ainsi arrêté près de 4000
personnes des centaines ont fini
derrière les barreaux avec des peines de
plus en plus sévères
certains de ses braconniers repentis
œuvres maintenant activement à protéger
les animaux
c'est le cas de Nicolas chef de l'unité
canine
est aujourd'hui un atout précieux pour
les garde-chasse il est où
la musique
[Musique]
patrouille en permanence son territoire
du haut désert pour suivre les
déplacements des animaux et essayer de
repérer des braconniers mais selon
Francis le vrai secret de la réussite
dans la lutte contre le braconnage c'est
l'appui des populations
doivent trop commune
ne cache pas cette fierté une bataille a
été remportée mais la guerre il le sait
est loin d'être terminé car le marché
pour les produits du braconnage et
mondial seul une réponse collective
selon lui permettra de venir à bout de
ce fléau
laisse stats
[Musique]